dans le comté de Jackson Caroline du
Nord mon nom de famille imposait le
respect
le crime faisait partie de notre ADN
tout comme notre taille ou notre couleur
de cheveux
dans le comté de Jackson la
méthamphétamine était une véritable
personne physique dont mon père était le
cœur tout le monde savait que c'était
pas le genre de type qu'on avait envie
de
croiserons ce mode de vie c'est lui qui
nous choisit et ce sera comme ça jusqu'à
notre dernier souffle qui a été la
gentille à sa carnet à la minute où tu
es venu au monde faut vraiment que tu
t'en altes ici faut que tu t'éloignes de
ton père lorsque je serai élu gouverneur
je compte bien faire de cette ville un
endroit plus sûr et plus
j'ai pas de chacun de nous
compter soit je te jure que je te clou
au pilori
les mains en l'air fais ce que je te dis
mets les mains en évidence
c'est pas comment te le dire tu es tout
pour moi je rêve de me tirer du fric
j'en ai il dort au chaud dans le coffre
de mon père
tu veux pas mieux que ton père
est-ce que tu penses
trouver des solutions